Hi, this is Rob Pleasure and I'm the Scoutmaster for Troop 18 in Muskega, Wisconsin.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers just like me.
And now it's the old Scoutmaster.
This just in from the ScoutmastersCGcom Institute for Advanced Camping Physics.
After extensive study, it has been revealed that the probability that a given piece of gear is left at home
is indeed proportionate to its usefulness.
How about that? I think we kind of suspected that.
Yeah, the most important thing that you actually need on a camping trip.
you can see a picture of it in your mind sitting on your table back at home sometimes.
Oh my, I've been there, I know you have too.
Hey, listen, this is podcast number 205..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag. this week,
Bill Monroe posted a review of the Scoutmaster CG app,
And if you want to have an easy way to access the blog and the podcast,
you can get the app on Google Play and you can also get it on iTunes.
But he said it's a great resource. just as our Troop is having questions,
Scoutmaster CG seems to be right there offering help.
That's right, Bill. we have agents everywhere reporting in on the activity in your troops right now.
I know it might seem like it, but, truth be told, we all go through the same things
and we all have the same questions
And getting together here can give you a little bit of relief
and it can be some help sometimes.
Scott Oath wrote on our Facebook page that he had just returned from teaching
at Northern Tears, Ockpick Cold Weather Leader Training.
It was an awesome week. He said it was very cold.
We had our crews out for the night at minus 35 degrees Fahrenheit.
That's really cold, Scott.
I've also taught at Northern Star Council's Minneapolis-St Paul Winter Camping School.
Ockpick is a program that happens up at Northern Tier
one of the BSA's National High Adventure Bases
And if you'd like to check out what happened up there that week,
Scott put some pictures up and talks about the whole course-
Really interesting photo journal that he set up
And there's a link on how to find that on the post that contains this podcast.
We also heard from James Keefe and James said
Great job with everything. I always look forward to new posts
and it's even better to catch up with the new Android app.
From time to time I still browse scoutmastercgcom,
but the site isn't displaying properly in my preferred browser,
and that is Firefox.
Thanks for all your hard work on the behalf of scouts and scouters everywhere.
Well, thank you, James.
I know that the old site, the cranky old site,
does not display right in every single browser,
And I've known about the Firefox problem for a little while.
I know I've been talking about this for several weeks now,
but as a result of the support that we have received from those of you
who have become scoutmastercgcom backers,
I'm excited to announce that by the end of this week-
yes, actually this week- the new scoutmastercgcom will be live.
I can't tell you exactly what day and what hour,
because it takes time for the changes on the site
to propagate out throughout the web,
But the process should be complete, if all goes well, by the end of the week.
Now the new version of the site has some significant new features
that I hope you'll find useful,
and we've talked about them a little bit here.
There's going to be a Scouter's Forum,
which will be a web forum for discussion
with your fellow scouters from all over the country
and all over the world.
There's a whole new section that we introduced to you last week,
called Scout's Forum,
and it's specifically for youth leaders
and it's authored by Enoch,
and it will have its own forum exclusively for youth leaders.
Our Scout Circle presentations,
our monthly live video presentations,
are now going to be hosted at scoutmastercgcom,
and I'm working on a live chat feature
that will make interacting with the presentation
a whole lot simpler.
I'm also working on a couple of other features too,
so stay tuned, but by the end of this week
I really, really hope you're going to start to see those changes
at the new scoutmastercgcom.
Once again, this would not be possible
if it wasn't for people becoming backers,
and becoming a backer means
that you're helping out financially
with the blog and the podcast
and all of the resources that we work to create.
If you're a regular reader or listener
and you find what we're doing has been helpful to you,
you can help keep things up and running
by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
Funds from backers go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing the blog
and the podcasts and the videos
that are becoming a valuable resource
to scouters all over the world.
So go to scoutmastercgcom
and follow the link to become a backer
In this week's podcast.
well, we're going to talk about a familiar subject.
They came up again this week
on a conversation that I had with a scouter friend.
Honestly, I don't think it's something
that we can talk about too much,
but we'll be talking about leadership positions,
positions of responsibility
and how to evaluate them,
And then we have several great email questions
that came in over the past week.
That's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started. shall we
Scout MasterChip? in seven minutes
Or less,
Let's go.
I was having an online conversation
with a scouter friend
and he said that when a scout goes
for a scout master conference
or border review,
there's nothing that can necessarily be done
to prevent that scout
from claiming the fulfillment
of a leadership position,
even if they never did anything for it,
And that he was trying to create
standards, specific for their troop,
that will still meet the BSA
expectations but aren't so rigid
that they scare scouts away
from leadership positions
or prevent good scouts
who are growing and showing effort
but don't meet all the standards
from getting credit.
And this sounds like a great idea, doesn't it?
A lot of scouts reach the point
where they're a little frustrated
with their ability to inspire scouts
towards responsibility and leadership.
They see themselves
evaluating positions
of responsibility-
We're going to talk about that in depth here-
But they see themselves
trying to evaluate this
and they don't really have any standards
or any written things
to hand and they feel like
it's a very difficult process
and that there are scouts
who don't do anything
in a leadership position
of responsibility other than wearing a patch,
and they feel like
this is unfair.
I want to unpack the whole subject once again
and talk about it once again,
because it is something that comes up frequently.
Now, you can't
and shouldn't
create a set of standards for this.
Now think about this.
If a set of standards that are written down
somewhere, some metrics,
that kind of pin all this down-
would be useful,
Somebody would have come up with these
and they would be printed in the Scoutmaster Handbook-
Right.
But you're not going to find anything like that
in an entire century of
Scoutmaster Handbooks.
We don't need them.
We don't want to address the question
with that kind of an answer.
I want to further say it's impossible
for a scout to get to the end
of the tenure in his position
of responsibility
and for there to be any question
if they have fulfilled that tenure,
if the Scoutmaster
is doing their job.
We need to talk about an important distinction
because,
in the shorthand that we develop as Scouters
we call
the Senior Patrol Leader,
Patrol Leader, Quartermaster, Scribe
and all the other positions that are defined
in the Scout Handbook
to be leadership positions.
But if you look carefully
you'll see that all the requirements
in our life in Eagle
do not call these leadership positions at all.
They call them positions
of responsibility.
One of the other perennial questions is:
is how does somebody like the Scribe
or the Quartermaster demonstrate leadership?
Well, not every position
that a Scout occupies in a troop
is necessarily a leadership position.
Some of them
are required that a Scout be
responsible
for what needs to be done
to get the job complete correct.
So there's an important distinction here.
It's important to look at these positions
for what they are:
Positions of responsibility.
So what we are evaluating
principally
is not some kind of fuzzy
leadership standard.
We are looking at
the level of responsibility
that Scouts
progress in,
both through the tenure in one of those positions.
Now, does that make sense?
It should be a reasonably simple thing to do.
It's the level of
progress
in responsibility
that Scouts achieve
in the tenure of that position.
Now I want to go back to the idea that
it's impossible
to get to a Scoutmaster conference
or a border review
and have there be any question
as to whether these things were fulfilled.
if the Scoutmaster
is doing their job-
And what I mean by that is
I talk to each one of my Scouts
holding a position of responsibility
several times a month.
I know what they're doing.
If there are any concerns about
how they're doing the job,
we talk about them.
We don't wait six months later
at a Scoutmasters conference for me to announce:
well, I've been watching you do this job
and I don't think you're doing it very well,
so I'm not going to count this
towards your advancement.
That's unfair.
I make sure that Scouts know
what is expected of them,
largely by asking them to tell me
what they think is expected of them.
When they tell me what the job
that they're taking on involves
and what they feel constitutes success
in that position,
then we have a shared understanding
of what's going on.
I may add to what they think
they may have, but not usually.
They usually get it,
And then I'm very conscious
of keeping up with them.
If they don't show up, it's my job
to find out why. If things are going
badly, I talk to the Scout
and I encourage them to do better.
Again, by asking them questions
about what's going on, I get them
to explain to me what they are doing,
or perhaps what they're not doing,
And I ask: if you were me
right now,
would you sign off the
requirement related to this position
of responsibility for your next rank?
Would you do that for yourself?
Now, sometimes this talk
can get a little strained, but Scouts
are good people and they get it
and they do what needs to be done
the majority of the time.
I've learned the hard way that Scouts
have all the answers
when I limit myself to asking questions,
And this is a hard one for me.
But if I take the time to really listen-
and again,
not so easy for me-
I can get a good idea of what they're thinking
and we develop a shared understanding
about these things.
If I was to just dictate
to them a job description-
and I had a checklist of metric
evaluations that I was going to make about
the way that they're doing it-
that's not necessarily a shared understanding, is it?
Now I will tell you
that, as a younger Scout Master,
like you, I was frustrated
with the kind of cavalier way that Scouts
treat their responsibilities.
Working with the committee chairman,
at one point we decided
that we were we had had about enough
of that and we created
a leadership contract
explaining exactly what the
responsibilities were, and we
asked the Scout to sign that contract
and we did this with a great
moment in ceremony
and we tried to emphasize to them
how important it was to sign
a contract and that
this was something that
represented that they understood exactly
what was happening.
What a great idea that seemed to be.
I mean, all a 13 to a 17 year old
needs is something like a contract
and then, being
magically, they'll take things seriously.
Now, of course, these contracts
weren't worth the paper
that they were printed on.
They had zero effect, because
we're working with boys between
ages of 13 and 17
for the most part
in these positions of responsibility.
they don't understand these things.
that's why we're there
to get them to understand,
to help them progress
in responsibility,
And these silly contracts that we came up
with really just served as a way
to humiliate or bledge and Scouts,
as righteous adults often like to do.
I've talked about this in the past
with several different things in Scouting.
here's what's important in these
kind of judgment call:
advancement requirements
Not the achievement of some particular
standard,
but the progress that a Scout
makes during his tenure
in the position, and that is
a very individual standard.
Some Scouts are
tremendously responsible
and they progress to being even more
responsible during the tenure in that position.
Some Scouts, just by nature,
are not very responsible. They're not
very awake and they don't look around
and they don't see what needs to be done
and they have to be reminded constantly.
After a number of months
occupying a position of responsibility,
has their awareness
and has their own sense of personal
responsibility and teamwork developed.
that's the standard that we're looking for.
So, just to review,
let's start talking
in terms of positions of responsibility
rather than leadership positions.
that, I think, helps clarify the
matter. Yes, we're still developing
leadership. Yes, we're still
doing all of those things,
but I think it helps clarify
it in your mind if you think about the development
of responsibility.
Second, we are looking
for progress.
We haven't ever in a
century of Scouting we haven't
seen it necessary to create
a specific metric
standard that indicates
a Scout is responsible,
And the reason
we haven't done it is because
it's based on individual progress.
Now, I know we'll come back and we'll talk
about this again and again. It's one of
the most important things for us to understand
to Scouters and it helps us
achieve the aims of Scouting
when we apply it properly.
Two one, let's
start the
fun.
Let's go
Email. that is, folks,
And here's an answer to one
of your emails.
Oh,
we had a number
of email questions come in this week.
We heard from Tracy,
who wrote in to say this:
my son has completed
all the requirements for Eagle
except the Eagle border review.
He had all of his requirements
signed off before
January 1st 2014..
Does he have to have cooking
Meribadge when all he really needs
to have is his Eagle border review?
His scout master seems to think he needs
to earn cooking Meribadge since it's
2014.. Now he
really has no problem doing the Meribadge,
but it doesn't seem fair to me.
Is there any way I can find this
information? any help would be appreciated.
That's a really good question
and I'm sure that it's occurring
in other places, so I think it's worth
talking about here on the podcast.
What I did just to make sure I had this
right, was I
shared Tracy's question
with the National Advancement Team
and you can get in touch with the National Advancement
Team anytime at this email address.
so you're ready. It's advancementteam,
advancementteam,
advancementteam
at scoutingorg
and within a day or so you'll get a good
answer back. It's a great resource.
I got this answer back. If all
Eagle requirements 1 through 6
have been completed by
12,, 31,, 13
and all that is remaining
is the border review,
then cooking Meribadge is not
required.
So that is about as authoritative as an answer
as you can get and I hope that helps resolve
the issue. Also heard from Christine
Bennett, who had this question:
where do we display old rank patches?
At a recent court of honor
I saw several scouts who had
previously earned rank patches
sewn on the back of their Meribadge
sash. Is this acceptable?
Well, Christine, this is a pretty easy
answer. It's in the Guide to
Awards in Insignia published by the BSA.
What you're dealing with here
is called XS Insignia. These
are rank patches that the scouts
have earned and they've moved on,
and so they have a new patch on their uniform.
so what do they do with the old ones? Well,
and this is what the guide says,
with the exception of Cub Scout
badges, of rank and arrow points,
which all stay on the uniform
during the whole time of boy, as a Cub Scout,
members wear only the insignia
that shows their present status
in the movement. Members should
make every effort to keep their uniforms neat
and uncluttered. Previously
earned badges in Insignia
not representing present status. make a fine
display on a red patch
vest or a blanket or in a
frame or something like that. Boy Scouts
may wear only
temporary patches, That's like
Campery patches and things like that.
No badges of rank
on the back of the Meribad sash.
So that's pretty clear, isn't it?
Now my personal advice to all
of us is to wear the
insignia and uniform properly
and be a good example of that And to answer
politely if we're asked
questions about how to wear
patches or how to wear the uniform,
but to refrain
from correcting anybody other
than the Scouts in our own unit.
and even then we're going to make
those corrections in the best
spirit of being helpful and friendly
and kind. Right
And courteous, Christine, I hope
that helps answer your question. James
Zappelli is Scoutmaster of Troop
208 and he wrote in
to ask: does your troop use the troop
program features booklets
as an aid to planning troop meetings?
Do your Scouts find this to be a helpful
resource? Would you be willing to share
a copy of your troops yearly plan
and or a copy of actual
written plans for one of the troop meetings?
I'm striving to do a better job
in teaching and coaching our Scouts on how
to run a successful,
productive, fun troop meeting.
Well, Jim, we are usually
about three months ahead of ourselves
so far as the annual plan goes. Now I
know most people have it a little
more together and they have an annual
plan mapped out. We have
target dates for everything and we let
everybody know, and,
but at least three months ahead of time
we have everything locked down.
Some people, like I said,
are a little bit better at that than we
are. As for meeting plans,
I doubt that there's much that gets written
down. I occasionally look over
the senior patrol leader's shoulder at what they have
scrawled on a piece of paper,
but to me it looks like a Kenea form
tablet from the Mesopotamians.
you know, My Scouts
are never all that interested
in writing things down, even
though I ask them to and I encourage
them to all the time.
Not all that interested to do that,
but they manage to present
some pretty good meetings anyway.
I find this endlessly puzzling.
I guess my memory
and the way I need to do things.
I've got to put things on a piece of paper,
but maybe when you're younger you don't
have to do that quite so much. I would say
that most of their meetings are fun,
probably fewer in number
are productive, but they all seem to
be successful. somehow. Our patrol
leaders council meets just before and just
after every meeting and they go over the next
meeting's plans. Now they usually have
some sort of idea of what they want to do,
but every once in a while they don't prepare
and things go south and we use that
as a teachable moment. I frequently
see them sitting at a table before a meeting
is going to begin and I ask what they're
doing. They usually look up at me
and they said: well, we're planning.
and I ask them if they are done planning
actually- and they need
to start preparing. and they kind
of roll their eyes at me and they go: yeah, you're
right, and they get up from the table and they start
preparing. Scouts plan
at the speed of talk. You know
who's going to do what. when are they going to do it?
that's basically their plan. It takes
them 5 minutes at most to plan a meeting.
What they often forget to do
is get up from the table at that point
and prepare what they're going to do. They think
planning and preparation is the same
thing. so maybe one of the keys
to helping your
scouts figure this out is
differentiating between planning
and preparation. Planning takes
5 minutes. You figure out who's going to do
what and when they're going to do it,
and then you got to get up from the table
and you got to go and prepare for it. You actually
have to prepare for those things.
You can't just talk about them and consider
them done, right, James? I hope
that helps. Chris Johnson
got in touch with us via
the app and he said:
hello. First off, I just
found the podcast and website in the app
and they're awesome. I've been a scout master
in northern Indiana for 5 years
and I love it. I was speaking to
a scout recently
and, inspired by what I heard on your podcast,
I asked him: why do you
want to be a scout? And without missing
a beat, he looked at me and said:
I don't want to be a scout. My parents
pushed me into scouts, so that's why I'm here.
I was kind of shocked-
I've never had a scout say this to me before-
and I was taken aback.
After we sat and talked for a while,
I found out that he missed
his dad, who travels all week.
I told him that we would talk again
soon, but in the meantime, I asked
him to do three things: To
think about the scout, oath and law and do
his best to put it into practice,
and that on his way home
from the meeting every week. to
think about the things that he liked about the meeting.
and to think about
how scouting might be able to help him
in his future, and why. And then
we'll talk about that when we get back
together. I'm curious to know how
you would have handled this. I appreciate
your time and keep up the good work. Thank you
well. Thanks, Chris, for getting in touch.
I think you handled your reluctant scout very
well. You sat and you listened
and you learned something about what was going
on. You encouraged him and you let him
know that you'd both be making the best
of what, for him, is a very difficult
situation. I think it's
good to remember that boys are kind of
barometric when it comes to changing attitudes.
if you haven't noticed right,
They can be on top of the world one moment,
down in the dumps the next.
They're looking for the same thing. we're all looking
for some affirmation in somebody to tell
them that they're okay and that we
all have difficult, challenging times,
but we get over them. Whenever I'm faced
with this sort of thing. I try my best
to think about what I would want to hear
if I was in that scout's shoes.
Your reply wasn't
judgmental or discouraging. You listen
carefully and you respond it appropriately,
and I think that's the best we can hope
for. It's amazing,
isn't it, What simple kindness
can do and how profoundly
it can affect the life of a scout.
I don't think I could offer you
much more advice over what you did, Chris,
I think you got this one right.
Thanks for getting in touch. If you
have a question, you can get in touch with me,
and you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks for listening to this
205th edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch.
The blog is available at
scoutmastercgcom
and while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can get the Scoutmaster
CG app on Google Play
or the iTunes app store.
You'll be able to access the blog
and the podcast and all of the other
resources that we can offer you.
You can also experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social
media outlets.
You can join the 4,700 folks who like
Scoutmaster Blog on Facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of 900
tweeters on Twitter.
or pin the Pultritudinous pictures
proffered publicly with 1200 plus
other prolific pinners on Pinterest
and watch us, if you dare,
at Scoutmaster CG on YouTube.
Or you can join the 400
odd folks who form the exclusive
Scoutmaster CG Circle
on Google Plus.
Now listen, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you bitter,
if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
if you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus,
that's alright, Bunky,
Just zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
That's right. you can email me,
Clark Green, your comments and questions
and all those wild ideas that you have
at scoutmastercgcom.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E
It only remains for me to say
that the Scoutmaster Blog and the Scoutmaster
Podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts
of America, or anybody else for that matter,
other than our ScoutmasterCGcom
backers. that's right.
It's just me talking into a microphone
and trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
Speaking of fun,
we sign off with this message
from our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pel.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Well, I thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.